So this week we've had the google thing,
there was the youtube thing that
happened last week,
what's going on with censorship and what
should people do about it?
If you're in a workplace in
pathological,
things are happening.
This is easy.
I can tell you how you know of
pathological things are happening at
your workplace or they're happening with
you one of the two.
But you can straighten that out if
you're being required to do things that
make you weak and ashamed,
then stop.
Don't do them.
Like one of the things I learned from
Solzhenitsyn and Frankl was that
systems go terribly under,
out of control when people don't stop
them,
when they're going mildly out of
control.
You know,
when you might say,
I should just keep my goddamn head down
and shut up.
It's like maybe you should like,
that's not bad advice.
You know,
you don't want to make unnecessary
enemies and you don't need any more
trouble than you need,
but you got to ask yourself on a day to
day basis what makes you think you're
not selling your soul?
You know?
And there's so much foolishness going on
in the mid level bureaucratic world now
that's where all the tyranny seems to be
focused.
And the reason that it multiplies is
because sensible people say nothing
when they should say something.
And what's so strange about that is that
there are way more sensible people than
people who aren't sensible.
They're just not as noisy.
So what you'll turn out if like,
so let's say something's bugging the
hell out of you at work,
well then you have to prepare it to find
another job.
That's the first thing you have to do.
I don't think that you should find
another job,
but you should prepare to find another
job.
And if possible,
you should prepare to find a better job.
Because if you can't tell someone to go
to hell,
then you can't negotiate with them.
And if and if they've got you over a
barrel,
then you can't say anything.
So you gotTa,
you gotta set yourself up.
So you've got some mobility and actually
that's a really good principal in your
life,
period.
You should set yourself up so that you
have a lateral move at hand.
And then you should find out,
well,
are there things at work that are
disturbing my soul?
You know,
and you find that out.
First of all,
you ask yourself,
okay,
I'm disturbed at work.
Okay,
I'm probably week and deceitful and
useless and lazy.
He might as well start with that.
And then you talk to some people like
your wife,
your friends,
your coworkers,
and find out are you stupid,
deceitful and lazy,
or is there something not so good going
on at work?
And so if you,
if you can then eliminate your own
personal pathology as a cause of your
dissatisfaction,
then maybe there's something rotten in
the state of Denmark and maybe you
should say something about it before the
whole goddamn thing collapses.
Because that can happen.
It can happen in companies a lot faster
than people ever think.
You know?
And you may find that,
well,
first of all may find if you say
something,
well first of all,
that's an adventure.
That's for sure.
That's a bloody adventure.
And you have to do it carefully and,
and you have to be prepared for it.
But it might be the best thing that ever
happened to you.
And the other thing is if you're careful
about it,
you get your words right.
Like in this is a,
this is strategic battle,
right?
It's not something you wander into
carelessly.
Then you may find that there's lots of
people who feel exactly the same way you
do and that you've actually caught and
onto something.
You're a canary in a coal mine and not
just some like psychopathic mouthpiece.
So you got to ask yourself,
when you go and do what you do like,
is this making you stronger?
Is this making you weaker?
And if it's making you weaker,
then you got to ask yourself,
do you really want to be weaker?
Because the weaker you get,
the more your tyrannized.
And then worse than that,
like the weaker you get,
the more bitter you get.
And the more you'll work towards
terrible things,
the more you'll snap it your wife,
the more you'll kick your kids.
You know,
like it's no joke to be tyrannized at
work.
And so I would say you have an ethical
responsibility as a citizen to
forthrightly confront,
creeping tyranny,
no matter where it occurs.
And part of,
part of what we're learning,
I would say from these stories,
if we're learning anything at all,
is that if you're aimed at the good,
which is a question you really got to
ask yourself,
you know,
if you're genuinely aimed at the good,
then take heart because you're a lot
stronger than you think.
So
I have a followup question.
Okay.
So I'm speaking to,
there's lots of people who were in this
situation like,
you know,
people at universities and corporations
all over the place.
I,
you know,
Google is not the only company that is
not the worst repressive,
uh,
freedom of speech,
denying workplace codes and everybody
feels alone,
right?
They're all like,
why should I stand up,
be a martyr,
get fired.
This guy at Google got fired.
Yeah.
What's the point?
And like,
I'm asking rhetorically.
No,
it's a good question.
And how do you,
how do you convince people that there's
a point to,
to standing up when it appears to be
futile?
Okay.
Well,
the first thing I think is you convince
them that it's not few tiles.
It might be difficult,
but it's not futile.
If you get your words right,
you have something to say.
There'll be an impact of those words.
It might not be the impact that you
would choose,
but the.
But the other thing you got to tell
people is pick your poison.
You don't.
You may be in a situation where you
don't have a.
You don't have a cake.
Walk to the garden of Paradise.
You got tyranny or famine.
Those are your choices,
but you get to pick which one you have.
And I would say if,
if you're being oppressed and I mean in
your soul by what you're required to
swallow at work,
well you think you're not paying a price
for that.
You got no self respect and,
and,
and rightly so,
but worse than that,
you're an agent of your own destruction.
You're destroying your own ideal and
you're letting people who are weak and
corrupt when
and if you stood up and stood up
properly,
but you have to put yourself in order to
do this.
At least to some degree,
right?
You can't do it casually.
You have to do it from some position of
preparedness and strength.
Then what makes you think you couldn't
scare them back into the corners and
that would be a good thing and you know
the alternative personally is bad
because there's a psychological
degeneration that goes along with it.
I've seen this with many,
many of the people that I've worked with
who have been tyrannized in the
workplace to the absolute detriment of
their psychological and physical health.
Right?
To the point of collapse confronting
these crazy,
crazy things when they were sensible
people.
That's a terrible price to pay man.
Like it's,
it's a bad price.
And then if the foolishness isn't dealt
with at the local level when it's still
relatively trivial,
then it will multiply until it's dealt
with at the social level and we're
seeing signs of that already on two fa
is a good sign of that,
you know,
and problems that aren't solved.
Multiply and soon people fight and you
know,
edit,
argue,
then to fight.
Unless you want to fight and some people
want to fight and I can understand why,
but I wouldn't recommend it because
that doesn't lead good places.
It really doesn't lead good places,
so I would say you have a duty.
Maybe that's,
that's where you stand up.
It's because you have a god damn duty to
stand up and say,
just say what you have to say it.
You don't even have to be trying to make
a point.
Exactly.
You're trying to get something done.
It's like,
this is how it looks to me.
That's what that guy had.
Google did.
He wrote this memo and he said he.
I talked to him today.
He said,
well,
he went to a diversity training seminar
and he thought,
no,
I don't agree with that.
And so then they asked for feedback.
So we wrote this document a month ago.
This was written a month ago.
Got No real response to it.
Well,
it bounced around inside Google until a
lot of people got interested in that.
It escaped into the outside world,
but all he was doing was.
He was told a bunch of things he didn't
think were true.
He wrote down a bunch of things he
thought were probably true.
He launched that out and said,
well,
I think these things are probably true.
It's like,
well,
probably their true well,
so he paid a price for it,
but maybe we'll see what sort of price
he paid for it,
man.
It's going to be a lot tougher in two
years than he was two years ago.
So.
No,
no,
they didn't answer his feedback.
No,
no,
but,
well,
you can watch the video,
the stories there,
but that's kind of the outline of it.
So,
sorry to monopolize this.
I have one other question about this and
I think it's important,
aside from Google just being a
workplace,
right?
It also controls the on Youtube,
Which,
which is post a new censorship scheme,
um,
and it controls a huge amount of the
information that people get.
And so true.
And so what happens to society when
companies such as Google,
which control our information start to
censor,
not just how about ourselves and maybe
the information that's coming out to the
rest of the world.
How much is this already happening and
how much?
How about if we would have,
if we refuse to find out,
that would be good.
You know,
like I reviewed this,
this guy's document,
I did that yesterday and everything he
said was validated by the scientific
literature.
So what has happened is that someone has
been fired publicly by a major
corporation for stating well grounded
scientific truths right there.
Exactly the sorts of things that I say
in my classes for example.
And the reason that I say to them is
because I read the literature.
It's not because I'm personally happy
about the fact.
I think Iq research particularly is so
dismal that you can't possibly read it
without being seriously disheartened.
If I could reconstruct the world.
So that ICU,
the ICU research wasn't true.
Well,
it should be tempting,
you know,
but that's not how science works.
Science doesn't tell you what you,
what you want to hear,
it just tells you the way it bloody well
is,
and he got pilloried for.
He got pilloried for revealing a good
fraction of current scientific knowledge
about gender differences.
Okay.
That's not good.
And as you said,
that's a big company and it controls our
communication.
It's how about we do what we can to
ensure that these large communication
companies don't get to impose a
factually false ideological structure on
the rest of the planet where you can
think about supporting this.
This guy who blew the whistle,
there's a fundraiser for him online.
He could use some money.
He wants to sue google.
Yeah,
thank you.
Maybe we could.
Maybe we could let
them know that hiring a human resources
director who's also concerned with
equity is probably not a good idea for
capitalist company.
Why in the world would you hire your own
enemies?
I don't understand that so.
Well,
we'll see how the dialogue continues,
but back to the personal like you need
to say what you think because that's
where you come from.
Right?
And if you don't say what you think,
then you kill your unborn self.
That's what you do.
That's what Cain did when he killed
Abel.
And that's why his punishment was
unbearable.
You know you have things in you that are
struggling to come to the light.
That's the truth.
You need daughter and you need to either
that truth because without that truth,
who cannot live in the world because the
world is real and you need truth to live
in the world.
And if you stifle your truth,
well,
how,
how can that be anything but something
that brings about hell,
how could it be any other way?
So you think,
well,
why should you speak up?
That's easy because the consequences of
not speaking up,
although delayed are far worse.
That's the reason.
If,
if,
if it can't be courage,
it could at least be prudent.
So.
Yep.